ladies and Gentlemen please welcome the
newlyweds Mr and Mrs Simon Doyle
you must meet
congratulations Madam
well it's only the greatest detective
alive I suspect you invited me for
reasons other than the fun
we have the Karnak all to ourselves a
chef and enough champagne to fill the
Nile
when you have money no one is ever
really your friend
it's too late to change events it's time
to face the consequence
someone is dead
the crime is
murderer is one of you were you aware of
any grudges Adam is used to getting what
she wants
watching I feel safe here
[Music]
there are so many conflicting hates and
jealousies oh I like this did you see or
hear anything I did not trust her I
still don't what did you do last night
you accused me of murder
he accuses everyone of murder it is a
problem I admit
ically planned
who did this
[Music]
you are mad
can I not trust you what do you want me
to say
[Applause]
someone else is dead
lock the doors
the murderer is here and we'll stay
[Music]